for three four women they're dancing
dancing here okay
from next okay now oh
this one very open okay oh my god
how where oh my god drop yeah hijab
okay wake up make up okay or neck little
bit
i see brothers who drive around all day
working all day looking at every woman
that comes his way
admiring and lusting and
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah the
website is in the description link below
you can also use the discount code
salaam 10
for 10 of their products salaam alaikum
welcome to a better cartoon brothers and
sisters and dear friends hope you guys
will inshallah this video is not
clickbait we're actually going to be
reacting
to girls dancing on tick tock i hope you
guys are ready inshallah and ready for a
shock uh before i start one praise allah
the most most of the most trust or
praise is glory and gratitude belong to
you
thank you okay guys so basically i'm
here with my mom again the reason i've
got my mom on this one
uh you're going to find out why uh what
we're going to do is the following
um
so what's gonna happen is my mom's going
to be scrolling through the tick tock
yeah so she's going to be reacting to it
she's going to tell me every time she
sees an inappropriate girl
now that's the reason i got my mom here
because obviously i'm not going to be
doing that obviously as you guys know
and this is actually
the whole point of the video okay
because this is a very important
reminder for brothers specifically and
i'm going to tell you guys why
because a lot of the issues that happen
in relationships and marriages and
whatever it may be
it's relate to the related to this so
you
[Music]
is chest showing chest
chest is open yeah uh arm is open short
not yeah very short very short okay all
right next
uh she's have a cover good job yeah
heads up
okay wake up make up okay all
neck little bit or i see you sure next
little thing okay
up okay now oh this one
very open okay oh my god
all right very bad yeah yeah very bad
very bad
okay yes next next one is
man is woman uh together uh
women come in
the man's lap yeah how is the woman
dressed uh
and top one is shot okay all right next
no she's long hair is wearing the shirt
okay not nice yeah
yeah not full open is very short is very
short
very short yeah
okay next next one is woman walk as
wearing the black uh trousers black
trousers you see body
yeah his body is easy and tight
you know yeah the process of the sun
dressed but
naked yeah but and just just notice how
many times my mom's coming across girls
by the way
[Music]
this one oh this woman is oh my god very
damn different
yeah and the different hedgehog i don't
know
you see your body no no face just face i
look in the face
very different oh okay all right now
from next
next one next one is oh next one is
together babies
okay okay
oh oh my god one and now he's a woman
yeah kick the someone boxing boxing
is it dress snake the stretch
tight tight and top one okay next let's
do a little bit more okay
the dress is yellow
you see a body chest
is
[Music]
um
stop so now what we're going to do guys
is i want to play a video a very
powerful video from mohammed hoblos
yeah we're going to watch that with my
mom and i'm going to translate to after
so i hope you guys are ready here we go
brothers who drive around all day
working all day
looking at every woman that comes his
way admiring and lusting and
allahu akbar he comes around and he says
man i'm sick of my wife
yeah of course you're sick of your wife
had you spent 10
of the time you spent looking at other
people's women and you just
spent that time looking at what allah
gave you maybe you would appreciate
there as well
but you don't you're looking at the
things that don't belong to you
you look at things that are not yours
you're trying to live the life that is
not yours
just live your life
[Music]
you know i i want you to give
[Music]
people who spend so much time on social
media i want to make something clear
yeah
for those who think that i'm doing this
video because i don't
suffer from this in the context of like
i don't have my days where
low in the gas becomes a problem etc so
i want to make something clear
for those who praise me i want to make
very clear i ask allah to forgive me for
what you do not know about me and
i ask allah to make me better than the
assumptions you have of me
a
what my mom's saying is the same thing
that as you guys heard for yourself here
it's very important guys
this is for the brother specifically
yeah the heart doesn't desire what the
eyes don't see
if i brought you if you if he was a
caveman argument's sake
or if you've never ever in your life
come across a strawberry i bring you a
strawberry yeah
a strawberry that has maybe not your
your traditional way of what you think
strawberry looks like here let's suppose
this is how strawberry that
usually looks like here and then you
taste it
and you like it you're like wow this is
very delicious fruit yeah you don't have
a problem with the shape you're just
like okay this is how strawberry looks
like and this and
it's beautiful and you taste it yeah i'm
not trying to say women are strawberries
by me please i'm just trying to make a
point here
but if i come and bring you a thousand
different strawberry
strawberries with different shapes yeah
and different flavors
you are not going to appreciate the
first strawberry you're going to find
faults in there you're going to say oh
that one's better
brothers and sisters that's this is the
reason why allah subhanahu wa says in
the quran
to is told the believing men first to
lower their gaze
yeah and this is so fundamental if you
don't know what you're gay is you're not
going to be happy with your wife
don't think to yourself yes polygamy
marrying two three fours
i was legislated that it is from the
dean and we are we are proud of that in
the context of
it is from the religion and handle it
has many benefits to it if it's done
properly
but for the men out there who do not
know what they're gays who are
constantly looking at other women
your issue your solution is never going
to be getting them second one for a
third one for a four or five
because your problem is different when
you're watching pornography
and all this kind of stuff and you are
dehumanizing women and you're looking at
them so much that they we hear the
stories
certain guys start um forgive me forgive
me if there's kids watching this please
switch off
guys there are certain women yeah and
i'm saying that can't understand they
can't even get erection to please their
wife which is the right
why because because why because you're
too busy watching pornography and all
kinds of stuff
if you don't know where it gets if you
go to tiktok and all you're doing is
scrolling and like i said before
yeah this is why i try my best to
abstain from it i try my best to abstain
from it guys
and go into these pages lock it off
because you are going to find problems
and you're not going to find your wife
attractive because you're too busy
comparing it to other girls and these
girls have the full shebang
they have the makeup there's plastic
surgeries the tight clothes
the push-up bras you name it yeah okay
they have it all
so much so that i believe me if they
took all of that off you would say i
would be like
you're someone else you're totally
different brother yeah so the question
here is this bronze sisters
especially brothers if you don't lower
your gaze you are never going to be
happy with your wife
if you're a single man you're going to
watch these girls and you're going to
you know what's your criteria going to
be for marriage
and this is another issue i discussed in
the marriage documentary and the app
that we're developing for this very
purpose
because this is destroying marriages
it's causing divorce
because brother you're going to be too
concerned to go and find a wife
who's got you know
excuse my language you know a certain
shape of her backside and she has to
look certain i trust us to look in a
certain way and make up you're looking
for the wrong things you're marrying
someone just for their looks and when
you marry them and marry the character
and realize
what you what you've married into you're
going to be thinking wow you know her
looks and nothing is
so that's all going to come off at night
yeah in the morning she's she's going to
be
someone different yeah and what i mean
by that is i'm not seeing women ugly
women by their very nature they are
beautiful
yeah woman by the nature how allah
created them man when you look at a
woman yeah when i look at my wife
i'm like amazed at alma's creation i'm
like wow man
yeah besides me thinking she's wow and
she's the most beautiful woman to me
besides i'm like wow the way allah has
created you it's so
amazing and women are subhanallah
in this dilemma where they are made to
feel ugly and look ugly in a certain way
that they don't even feel comfortable to
go out the house without makeup
they've been sexualized to such a degree
that they get
called they're seen as nothing but a
sexual object read the book called
beauty sick
and you will see the studies that over
there how women are starving themselves
to look a certain way
guys i'm going to take talk you can
follow me on twitter for good reminders
etc
but i'm just letting you guys know
brothers if you're going to go on tiktok
and you're going to go on the story line
and
and this thing and while i ask allah to
forgive all of us well life forgive me
and forgive everyone we have our short
coming
but the point is this try your best make
dua allah protect my gaze
you've given me these eyes protected so
i can use it for the right means
well i brothers and sisters i live
jahili i use these eyes for so much
wrong so much wrong and i ask allah to
forgive me
but please guys all i'm saying is
brothers if you want this your marriage
to be successful
please stop looking at other women and
this is a reminder to myself first i
swear to god this is a reminder to
myself first
um because we all struggle with it but
please
if you don't do this you're not going to
be happy in your marriage the person
that you're going to choose from
marriage is going to be a disaster
and that's it and we're going to end
with that and i hope you guys enjoyed
this video share with your friends and
family
send this to your husbands your brothers
your uncles whoever maybe inshallah
until next time
exactly until next time